TOM SIMONITE: Hi.
Good morning.
Welcome to day
three of Google I/O,
and what should be a fun
conversation about machine
learning and artificial
intelligence.
My name is Tom Simonite.
I'm San Francisco bureau chief
for MIT Technology Review.
And like all of you, I've
been hearing a lot recently
about the growing power
of machine learning.
We've seen some striking
results come out
of academic and
industrial research labs,
and they've moved very quickly
into the hands of developers,
who have been using them to
make new products and services
and companies.
I'm joined by three
people this morning
who can tell us about
how this new technology
and the capabilities it brings
are coming out into the world.
They are Aparna
Chennapragada, who
is the director of
product management
and worked on the Google
Now mobile assistant,
Jeff Dean, who leads the Google
Brain research group here
in Mountain View,
and John Giannandrea,
who is head of search and
machine intelligence at Google.
Thanks for joining
me, all of you.
We're going to talk
for about 30 minutes,
and then there will be time
for questions from the floor.
John, why don't
we start with you?
You could set the scene for us.
Artificial intelligence
and machine learning
are not brand new concepts.
They've been around
for a long time,
but we're suddenly hearing
a lot more about them.
Large companies
and small companies
are investing more
in this technology,
and there's a lot of excitement.
You can even get a
large number of people
to come to a talk about this
thing early in the morning.
So what's going on?
Tell these people
why they're here.
JOHN GIANNANDREA:
What's going on?
Yeah, thanks, Tom.
I mean, I think in
the last few years,
we've seen extraordinary results
in fields that hadn't really
moved the needle for many
years, like speech recognition
and image understanding.
The error rates are just
falling dramatically,
mostly because of advances
in deep neural networks,
so-called deep learning.
I think these
techniques are not new.
People have been using neural
networks for many, many years.
But a combination of events
over the last few years
has made them much
more effective,
and caused us to invest
a lot in getting them
into the hands of developers.
People talk about it
in terms of AI winters,
and things like this.
I think we're kind of
an AI spring right now.
We're just seeing
remarkable progress
across a huge number of fields.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
And now, how long
have you worked
in artificial
intelligence, John?
JOHN GIANNANDREA:
Well, we started
investing heavily in this at
Google about four years ago.
I mean, we've been
working in these fields,
like speech recognition,
for over a decade.
But we kind of got serious
about our investments
about four years ago,
and getting organized
to do things that
ultimately resulted
in the release of things
like TensorFlow, which
Jeff's team's worked on.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
And we'll talk more about
that later, I'm sure.
Aparna, give us a perspective
from the view of someone
who builds products.
So John says this
technology has suddenly
become more powerful
and accurate and useful.
Does that open up
new horizons for you,
when you're thinking
about what you can build?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
Yeah, absolutely.
I think for me, these are
great as a technology.
But as a means to
an end, they're
powerful tool kits to help
solve real problems, right?
And for us, as building
products, and for you guys,
too, there's two ways
that machine learning
changes the game.
One is that it can turbo charge
existing use cases-- that
is, existing problems
like speech recognition--
by dramatically changing
some technical components
that power the product.
If you're building a voice
enabled assistant, the word
error rate that John was talking
about, as soon as it dropped,
we actually saw the usage go up.
So the product gets more usable
as machine learning improves
the underlying engine.
Same thing with translation.
As translation gets
better, Google Translate,
it scales to 100-plus languages.
And photos is a great example.
You've heard Sundar
talk about it, too,
that as soon as you have
better image understanding,
the photo labeling gets
better, and therefore, I
can organize my photos.
So it's a means to an end.
That's one way, certainly,
that we have seen.
But I think the second way
that's, personally, far more
exciting to see is where it can
unlock new product use cases.
So turbocharging existing
use cases is one thing,
but where can you
kind of see problems
that really weren't thought
of as AI or data problems?
And thanks to mobile, here--
3 billion phones-- a lot
of the real world problems
are turning into AI problems,
right?
Transportation,
health, and so on.
That's pretty exciting, too.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
And so is one
consequence of this
that we can make computers
less annoying, do you think?
I mean, that would be nice.
We'd all had these
experiences where
you have a very clear idea of
what it is you're trying to do,
but it feels like
the software is doing
everything it can to stop you.
Maybe that's a form of
artificial intelligence, too.
I don't know.
But can you make more
seamless experiences
that just make life easier?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Yeah.
And I think in this case,
again, one of the things
to think about is, how do
you make sure-- especially
as you build
products-- how do you
make sure your interface
scales with the intelligence?
The UI needs to be
proportional to AI.
I cannot believe I said some
pseudo formula in front of Jeff
Dean.
But I think that's
really important,
to make sure that the
UI scales with the AI.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
And Jeff, for
people like Aparna,
building products,
to do that, we
need this kind of
translation step
which your group is working on.
So Google Brain is
a research group.
Works in some very fundamental
questions in its field.
But you also build
this infrastructure,
which you're kind of inventing
from scratch, that makes
it possible to use this stuff.
JEFF DEAN: Yeah.
I mean, I think,
obviously, in order
to make progress on
these kinds of problems,
it's really important to be
able to try lots of experiments
and do that as
quickly as you can.
There's a very
fundamental difference
between having an
experiment take a few hours,
versus something
that takes six weeks.
It's just a very different
model of doing science.
And so, one of the
things we work on
is trying to build really
scalable systems that are also
flexible and easy to express
new kinds of machine learning
ideas.
So that's how
TensorFlow came about.
It's sort of our internal
research vehicle,
but also robust enough to take
something you've done and done
lots of experiments on, and
then, when you get something
that works well, to take that
and move it into a production
environment, run things
on phones or in data
centers, on RTPUs, that we
announced a couple days ago.
And that seamless
transition from research
to putting things
into real products
is what we're all about.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
And so, TensorFlow is this
very flexible package.
It's very valuable to Google.
You're building a lot
of things on top of it.
But you're giving
it away for free.
Have you thought this through?
Isn't this something you
should be keeping closely held?
JEFF DEAN: Yeah.
There was actually a little
bit of debate internally.
But I think we decided
to open source it,
and it's got a nice Apache
2.0 license which basically
means you can take it and
do pretty much whatever
you want with it.
And the reason we did
that is several fold.
One is, we think it's a really
good way of making research
ideas and machine learning
propagate more quickly
throughout the community.
People can publish
something they've done,
and people can
pick up that thing
and reproduce those people's
results or build on them.
And if you look
on GitHub, there's
like 1,500 repositories,
now, that mention TensorFlow,
and only five of
them are from Google.
And so, it's people doing all
kinds of stuff with TensorFlow.
And I think that free exchange
of ideas and accelerating
of that is one of the
main reasons we did that.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
And where is this going?
So I imagine, right now,
that TensorFlow is mostly
used by people who are quite
familiar with machine learning.
But ultimately, the
way I hear people
talk about machine
learning, it's
just going to be used
by everyone everywhere.
So can developers
who don't have much
of a background in this
stuff pick it up yet?
Is that possible?
JEFF DEAN: Yeah.
So I think, actually,
there's a whole set
of ways in which people can take
advantage of machine learning.
One is, as a fundamental
machine learning researcher,
you want to develop
new algorithms.
And that's going to be a
relatively small fraction
of people in the world.
But as new algorithms
and models are developed
to solve particular
problems, those models
can be applied in lots of
different kinds of things.
If you look at the use
of machine learning
in the diabetic
retinopathy stuff
that Sundar mentioned
a couple days ago,
that's a very similar problem
to a lot of other problems
where you're trying
to look at an image
and detect some part
of it that's unusual.
We have a similar
problem of finding text
in Street View images so
that we can read the text.
And that looks pretty
similar to a model
to detect diseased parts of an
eye, just different training
data, but the same model.
So I think the
broader set of models
will be accessible to
more and more people.
And then there's
even an easier way,
where you don't really need
much machine learning knowledge
at all, and that is to
use pre-trained APIs.
Essentially, you can
use our Cloud Vision API
or our Speech APIs very simply.
You just give us an image, and
we give you back good stuff.
And as part of the
TensorFlow flow open source,
we also released, for example,
an inception model that
does image classification that's
the same model as underlies
Google Photos.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
So will it be possible for
someone-- maybe they're
an experienced builder of
apps, but don't know much about
machine learning--
they could just
have an idea and kind of use
these building blocks to put it
together?
JEFF DEAN: Yeah.
Actually, I think one of the
reasons TensorFlow has taken
off, is the tutorials in
TensorFlow are actually
quite good at illustrating
six or seven important kinds
of models in machine
learning, and showing people
how they work, stepping through
both the machine learning
that's going on underneath,
and also how you express them
in TensorFlow.
That's been pretty
well received.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
And Aparna, I think
we've seen in the past
that when a new platform of mode
of interaction comes forward,
we have to experiment
with it for some time
before we figure out
what works, right?
And sometimes,
when we look back,
we might think, oh,
those first generation
mobile apps were kind of
clunky, and maybe not so smart.
How are we going
with that process
here, where we're starting
to have to understand
what types of interaction work?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Yeah.
And I think it's one of the
things that's not intuitive
when you start out, you
rush out into a new area,
like we've all done.
So one experience,
for example, when
we started working on Google
Now, one thing we realized
is, it's really
important to make sure
that, depending on the product
domain, some of these black box
systems, you need
to pay attention
to what we call internally
as the wow to WTH ratio.
That is, as soon
as you kind of say,
hey, there are some delightful
magical moments, right?
But then, if you
kind of get it wrong,
there's a high cost to the user.
So to give you an
example, in Google Search,
let's say you search for, I
don't know, Justin Timberlake,
and we got a slightly
less relevant answer.
Not a big deal, right?
But then, if the assistant
told you to sit in the car,
go drive to the
airport, and you missed
your flight, what the hell?
So I think it's really important
to get that ratio right,
especially in the early
stages of this new platform.
The other thing
we noticed also is
that explainability or
interpretability really builds
trust in many of these cases.
So you want to be
careful about looking
at which parts of the problem
you use machine learning
and you drop this into.
You want to look at problems
that are easy for machines
and hard for humans,
the repetitive things,
and then make sure that those
are the problems that you
throw machine learning against.
But you don't want to be
unpredictable and inscrutable.
TOM SIMONITE: And one mode of
interaction that everyone seems
to be very excited
about, now, is this idea
of conversational interface.
So we saw the introduction on
Wednesday of Google Assistant,
but lots of other companies
are building these things, too.
Do we know that
definitely works?
What do we know
about how you design
a conversational interface,
or what the limitations
and strengths are?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: I think,
again, at a broad level,
you want to make sure that
you can have this trust.
So [INAUDIBLE]
domains make it easy.
So it's very hard to make
a very horizontal system
work that works for anything.
But I'm actually pretty
excited at the progress.
We just launched-- open
sourced-- the sentence parser,
Parsey Mcparseface.
I just wanted to say that name.
But it's really exciting,
because then you say,
OK, you're starting to see the
beginning of conversational,
or at least a natural language
sentence understanding,
and then you have building
blocks that build on top of it.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
And John, with your search
hat on for a second,
we heard on Wednesday that,
I think, 20% of US searches
are now done by voice.
So people have clearly
got comfortable with this,
and you've managed
to provide something
that they want to use.
Is the Assistant
interface to search
going to grow in a
similar way, do you think?
Is it going to take over a
big chunk of people's search
queries?
JOHN GIANNANDREA: Yeah.
We think of the Assistant as a
fundamentally different product
than search, and
I think it's going
to be used in a different way.
But we've been
working on what we
call voice search
for many, many years,
and we have this
evidence that people
like it and are using it.
And I would say our key
differentiator, there, is just
the depth of search, and
the number of questions
we can answer, and the
kinds of complexities
that we can deal with.
I think language and dialogue
is the big unsolved problem
in computer science.
So imagine you're
reading an article
and then writing a
shorter version of it.
That's currently beyond
the state of the art.
I think the important thing
about the open source release
we did of the parser is it's
using TensorFlow as well.
So in the same way
as Jeff explained,
the functionality of this
in Google Photos for finding
your photos is actually
available open source,
and people can
actually play with it
and run a cloud version of it.
We feel the same way about
natural language understanding,
and we have many more
years of investment
to make in getting to really
natural dialogue systems,
where you can say
anything you want,
and we have a good shot
of understanding it.
So for us, this is a journey.
Clearly, we have a fairly usable
product in voice search today.
And the Assistant, we
hope, when we launch
later this year,
people will similarly
like to use it and
find it useful.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
Do you need a different
monetization model
for the Assistant dialogue?
Is that something--
JOHN GIANNANDREA: We're
really focused, right now,
on building something
that users like to use.
I think Google
has a long history
of trying to build things
that people find useful.
And if they find them useful,
and they use them at scale,
then we'll figure out a way
to actually have a business
to support that.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
So you mentioned
that there are still
a lot of open research
questions here,
so maybe we could talk
about that a little bit.
As you described,
there have been
some very striking improvements
in machine learning recently,
but there's a lot
that can't be done.
I mean, if I go to my
daughter's preschool,
I would see young children
learning and using
language in ways that your
software can't match right now.
So can you give us a summary
of the territory that's
still to be explored?
JOHN GIANNANDREA: Yeah.
There's a lot still to be done.
I think there's
a couple of areas
which researchers
around the world
are furiously trying to attack.
So one is learning from
smaller numbers of examples.
Today, the learning
systems that we have,
including deep neural
networks, typically
require really large
numbers of examples.
Which is why, as
Jeff was describing,
they can take a
long time to train,
and the experiment
time can be slow.
So it's great that
we can give systems
hundreds of thousands or
millions of labeled examples,
but clearly, small children
don't need to do that.
They can learn from very
small numbers of examples.
So that's an open problem.
I think another very important
problem in machine learning
is what the researchers call
transfer learning, which
is learning something
in one domain,
and then being able to
apply it in another.
Right now, you have
to build a system
to learn one particular
task, and then that's not
transferable to another task.
So for example, the
AlphaGo system that
won the Go
Championship in Korea,
that system can't, a priori,
play chess or tic tac toe.
So that's a big,
big open problem
in machine learning that lots
of people are interested in.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
And Jeff, this is kind of on
your group, to some extent,
isn't it?
You need to figure this out.
Are there particular
avenues or recent results
that you would highlight
that seem to be promising?
JEFF DEAN: Yeah.
I think we're making, actually,
pretty significant progress
in doing a better job of
language understanding.
I think, if you look at where
computer vision was three
or four or five
years ago, it was
kind of just starting
to show signs of life,
in terms of really
making progress.
And I think we're starting to
see the same thing in language
understanding kinds of models,
translation, parsing, question
answering kinds of things.
In terms of open problems,
I think unsupervised
learning, being able to
learn from observations
of the world that
are not labeled,
and then occasionally getting
a few labeled examples that
tell you, these are important
things about the world
to pay attention
to, that's really
one of the key open challenges
in machine learning.
And one more, I would
add, is, right now,
what you need a lot of
machine learning expertise for
is to kind of device the
right model structure
for a particular
kind of problem.
For an image problem, I should
use convolutional neural nets,
or for language problems, I
should use this particular kind
of recurrent neural net.
And I think one
of the things that
would be really
powerful and amazing
is if the system itself could
device the right structure
for the data it's observing.
So learning model
structure concurrently
with trying to solve some
set of tasks, I think,
would be a really great
open research problem.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
So instead of you having
to design the system
and then setting
it loose to learn,
the learning system would
build itself, to some extent?
JEFF DEAN: Right.
Right now, you kind of define
the scaffolding of the model,
and then you fiddle
with parameters
as part of the learning
process, but you don't sort of
introduce new kinds
of connections
in the model structure itself.
TOM SIMONITE: Right.
OK.
And unsupervised learning,
just giving it that label,
it makes it sound like
one unitary problem, which
may not be true.
But will big
progress on that come
from one flash of insight
and a new algorithm,
or will it be-- I don't
know-- a longer slog?
JEFF DEAN: Yeah.
If I knew, that
would be [INAUDIBLE].
I have a feeling that it's
not going to be, like,
100 different things.
I feel like there's
a few key insights
that new kinds of
learning algorithms
could pick up on
as to what aspects
of the world the model is
observing are important.
And knowing which
things are important
is one of the key things
about unsupervised learning.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
Aparna, so what Jeff's team
kind of works out, eventually,
should come through
into your hands,
and you could build
stuff with it.
Is there something
that you would really
like him to invent tomorrow,
so you can start building
stuff with it the day after?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
Auto generate emails.
No, I'm kidding.
I do think, actually, what's
interesting is, you've heard
these building blocks, right?
So machine perception, computer
vision, wasn't a thing,
and now it's actually reliable.
Language understanding,
it's getting there.
Translation is getting there.
To me, the next other building
block you can make machines do
is hand-eye coordination.
So you've seen the
robot arms video
that Sundar talked about
and showed at the keynote,
but imagine if you could kind
of have these rote tasks that
are harder, tedious
for humans, but if you
had reliable hand-eye
coordination built in, that's
in a learned system versus
a controlled system code
that you usually write,
and it's very brittle,
suddenly, it opens up a
lot more opportunities.
Just off the top of my
head, why isn't there
anything for,
like, elderly care?
Like, you are an 80-year-old
woman with a bad back,
and you're picking up things.
Why isn't there something there?
Or even something as mundane
with natural language
understanding, right?
I have a seven-year-old.
I'm a mom of a 7-year-old.
Why isn't there something
for, I don't know,
math homework, with natural
language understanding?
JOHN GIANNANDREA: So
I think one of things
we've learned in
the last few years
is that things that
are hard for people
to do, we can teach
computers to do,
and things that are
easy for us to do
are still the hard
problems for computers.
TOM SIMONITE: Right.
OK.
And does that mean we're still
missing some big new field
we need to invent?
Because most of the things
we've been talking about so far
have been built on top
of this deep learning
and neural network.
JOHN GIANNANDREA: I think
robotics work is interesting,
because it gives the
computer system an embodiment
in the world, right?
So learning from
tactile environments
is a new kind of learning,
as opposed to just looking
at unsupervised or supervised.
Just reading text is a
particular environment.
Perception, looking at
images, looking at audio,
trying to understand
what this song is,
that's another kind of problem.
I think interacting
with the real world
is a whole other
kind of problem.
TOM SIMONITE: Right.
OK.
That's interesting.
Maybe this is a good time
to talk a little bit more
about DeepMind.
I know that they are very
interested in this idea
of embodiment, the idea you
have to submerge this learning
agent in a world that
it can learn from.
Can you explain how
they're approaching this?
JOHN GIANNANDREA: Yeah, sure.
I mean, DeepMind is
another research group
that we have at Google, and
we work closely with them
all the time.
They are particularly interested
in learning from simulations.
So they've done a lot
of work with video games
and simulations of
physical environments,
and that's one of the research
directions that they have.
It's been very productive.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
Is it just games?
Are they moving into
different types of simulation?
JOHN GIANNANDREA: Well,
there's a very fine line
between a video game-- a
three-dimensional video game--
and a physics simulation
already environment, right?
I mean, some video
games are, in fact,
full simulations of worlds,
so there's not really
a bright line there.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
And do DeepMind
work on robotics?
They don't, I didn't think.
JOHN GIANNANDREA: They're
doing a bunch of work
in a bunch of different
fields, some of which
gets published, some
of which is not.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
And the robot arms that we saw
in the keynote on Wednesday,
are they within
your group, Jeff?
JEFF DEAN: Yes.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
So can you tell us
about that project?
JEFF DEAN: Sure.
So that was a collaboration
between our group
and the robotics teams in Google
X. Actually, what happened was,
one of our
researchers discovered
that the robotics
team, actually,
had 20 unused arms sitting
in a closet somewhere.
They were a model that was
going to be discontinued
and not actually used.
So we're like, hey, we should
set these up in a room.
And basically, just
the idea of having
a little bit larger scale
robotics test environment
than just one arm, which
is what you typically
have in a physical
robotics lab, would
make it possible to do a bit
more exploratory research.
So one of the first things
we did with that was just
have the robots learn
to pick up objects.
And one of the nice
properties that has,
it's a completely
supervised problem.
The robot can try
to grab something,
and if it closes its griper
all the way, it failed.
And if it didn't
close it all the way,
and it picked something
up, it succeeded.
And so it's learning from
raw camera pixel inputs
directly to torque
motor controls.
And there's just
a neural net there
that's trained to pick things up
based on the observations it's
making of things as it
approaches a particular object.
TOM SIMONITE: And is that
quite a slow process?
I mean, that fact that you
have multiple arms going
at once made me think
that, maybe, you
were trying to maximize your
throughput, or something.
JEFF DEAN: Right.
So if you have 20 arms, you get
20 times as much experience.
And if you think about how small
kids learn to pick stuff up,
it takes them maybe
a year, or something,
to go from being able to
move their arm to really be
able to grasp simple objects.
And by parallelizing
this across more arms,
you can pool the experience
of the robotic arms a bit.
TOM SIMONITE: I see.
OK.
JEFF DEAN: And they
need less sleep.
TOM SIMONITE: Right.
John, at the start
of the session,
you referred to this
concept of AI winter,
and you said you
thought it was spring.
When do we know
that it's summer?
JOHN GIANNANDREA:
Summer follows spring.
I mean, there's still a
lot of unsolved problems.
I think problems around
dialogue and language
are the ones that I'm
particularly interested in.
And so, until we can teach
a computer to really read,
I don't think we can
declare that it's summer.
I mean, if you can imagine
a computer's really reading
and internalizing a document.
So it's interesting.
So translation is reading
a paragraph in one language
and writing it in
another language.
In order to do that
really, really well,
you have to be
able to paraphrase.
You have to be able to reorder
words, and so on and so
forth So imagine
translating something
from English to English.
So you read a paragraph, and
you write a different paragraph.
If we could do that, I think
I would declare summer.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
Reading is-- well, there are
different levels of reading,
aren't there?
Do you know--
JOHN GIANNANDREA: If you can
paraphrase, then you really--
TOM SIMONITE: Then you
think that-- if you
could reach that level.
JOHN GIANNANDREA: And
actually understood--
TOM SIMONITE: Then
you've got some argument.
JOHN GIANNANDREA: And
to a certain extent,
today, our translation
systems, which
are not perfect by any
means, are getting better.
They do do some of that.
They do do some paraphrasing.
They do do some re-ordering.
They do do a remarkable amount
of language understanding.
So I'm hopeful researchers
around the world
will get there.
And it's very important to
us that our natural language
APIs become part of
our cloud platform,
and that people can
experiment with it, and help.
JEFF DEAN: One thing
I would say is,
I don't think
there's going to be
this abrupt line between
spring and summer, right?
There's going to be developments
that push the state of the art
forward in lots of
different areas in kind
of this smooth gradient
of capabilities.
And at some point,
something becomes
possible that didn't
used to be possible,
and people kind of
move the goalposts
of what they think of as
really, truly hard problems.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
The classic joke, right?
It's only AI until
it starts working,
and then it's computer science.
JEFF DEAN: Like, if you'd
asked me four years ago,
could a computer
write a sentence
given an image as input?
And I would have said,
I don't think they
can do that for a little while.
And they can actually
do that today,
and that's kind of a
good example of something
that has made a lot of
progress in the last few years.
And now you sort of say,
OK, that's in our tool
chest of capabilities.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
But if we're not that
great at predicting
how the progress goes, does
that mean we can't see winter,
if it comes back?
JOHN GIANNANDREA: If we
stop seeing progress,
then I think we could question
what the future's going
to look like.
But today, the rate of-- I
think researchers in the field
are excited about this,
and maybe the field
is a little bit over-hyped
because of the rate of progress
we're seeing.
Because something like
speech recognition,
which didn't work for
my wife five years ago,
and now works flawlessly,
because image identification
is now working better than
human raters for many fields.
So there's these narrow fields
for which algorithms are not
superhuman in
their capabilities.
So we're seeing
tremendous progress.
And so it's very exciting for
people working in this field.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
Great.
I should just note that,
in a couple of minutes,
we will open up the
floor for questions.
There are microphones here and
here in the main seating area,
and there's one microphone
up in the press area, which
I can't see right
now, but hopefully you
can figure out where it is.
Sundar Pichai, CEO of Google,
has spoken a lot recently
about how he thinks we're
moving from a world which
is mobile-first to AI-first.
I'm interested to hear
what you think that means.
Maybe, Aparna, you
could speak to that.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
I interpret
it a couple different ways.
One is, if you look at
how mobile's changed,
how you experience
computing, it's
not happened at one level
of the stack, right?
It's at the
interface level, it's
at the information level,
and infrastructure.
And I think that's
the same thing that's
going to happen with AI and
any of these machine learning
techniques, which is, you'll
have infrastructure layer
improvements.
You saw the
announcement about TPU.
You'll have a bunch of
algorithms and models
improvements at the intelligence
and information layer,
and there will be
interface changes.
So the best UI is
probably no UI.
TOM SIMONITE: Right.
OK.
John, what does
AI-first mean to you?
JOHN GIANNANDREA:
I think it means
that this assistant kind of
layer is available to you
wherever you are.
Whether you're in your
car, or whether it's
ambient in your house,
or whether you're
using your mobile
device or laptop,
that there is this
smart assistance
that you find very quietly
useful to you all the time.
Kind of how Google search
is for most people today.
I think most people would not
want search engines taken away
from them, right?
So I think that being
that useful to people,
so that people take
it for granted,
and then it's ambient
across all your devices,
is what AI-first means to me.
TOM SIMONITE: And we're in
the early stages of this,
do you think?
JOHN GIANNANDREA: Yeah.
It's a journey, I think.
It's a multi-year journey
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
Great.
So thanks for a
fascinating conversation.
Now, we'll let someone else ask
the questions for a little bit.
I will alternate between
the press mic and the mics
down here at the front.
Please keep your
questions short,
so we can get
through more of them,
and make sure they're
questions, not statements.
We will start with the
press mic, wherever it is.
MALE SPEAKER:
There's nobody there.
TOM SIMONITE: I really doubt
the press has no questions.
What's happening?
Why don't we start
with the developer mic
right here on the right?
AUDIENCE: I have a philosophical
question about prejudice.
People tend to have prejudice.
Do you think this
is a step stone
that we need to take in
artificial intelligence,
and how would
society accept that?
JOHN GIANNANDREA: I'm not sure
I understand the question.
Some people have prejudice, and?
AUDIENCE: Some people
have the tendency
to have prejudice, which
might lead to behaviors
such as discrimination.
TOM SIMONITE: So
the question is,
will the systems that the
people build have biases?
JOHN GIANNANDREA: Oh, I see.
I see.
Will people's prejudices creep
into machine learning systems?
I think that is a risk.
I think it all depends on the
training data that we choose.
We've already seen some issues
with this kind of problem.
So I think it all
depends on carefully
selecting training
data, particularly
for supervised systems.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
Is the press mic
working, at this point?
SEAN HOLLISTER: Hi.
I'm Sean Hollister, up
here in the press mic.
TOM SIMONITE: Great.
Go for it.
SEAN HOLLISTER: Hi, there.
I wanted to ask about the role
of privacy in machine learning.
You need a lot of data to
make these observations
and to help people
with machine learning.
I give all my photos
to Google Photos,
and I wonder what happens
to them afterwards.
What allows Google
to see what they
are, and is that ever shared
in any way with anyone else?
Personally, I don't care
very much about that.
I'm not worried my
photos are going
to get out to other folks,
but where do they go?
What do you do with them?
And to what degree
are they protected?
JEFF DEAN: Do you
want to take that one?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
I think this
is one of the most
important things
that we look at across products.
So even with photos,
or Google Now,
or voice, and all
of these things.
There's actually two principles
we codify into building this.
One is, there's
a very explicit--
it's a very transparent
contract between the user
and the product that is, you
basically know what benefits
you're getting with
the data, and the data
is there to help you.
That's one principle.
But the second is, by default,
it's an opt-in experience.
You're in the driver's seat.
In some sense, let's
say, you're saying,
hey, I do want to get
traffic information when
I'm on Shoreline, because
it's clogged up to Shoreline
Amphitheater, you, of
course, need the system
to know where your location is.
Because you don't want to know
how the traffic is in Napa.
So having that contract
be transparent, but also
an opt-in, I think it really
addresses the equation.
But I think the other
thing to add in here
is also that, by definition,
all of these are for your eyes
only, right?
In terms of, like, all your data
is yours, and that's an axiom.
JOHN GIANNANDREA: And
to answer his question,
we would never share his photos.
We train models based on other
photos that are not yours,
and then the machine
looks at your photos,
and it can label it,
but we would never
share your private photo there.
SEAN HOLLISTER: To what
degree is advertising
anonymously-targeted
at folks like me,
based on the contents
of things I upload,
little inferences you
make in the meta data?
Is any of that going to
advertisers in any way,
even in aggregate, hey,
this is a person who
seems to like dogs?
JOHN GIANNANDREA:
For your photos?
No.
Absolutely not.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: No.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
Let's go to this mic right here.
AUDIENCE: My questions
is for Aparna, about,
what is the thought process
behind creating a new product?
Because there are so many things
that these guys are creating.
So how do you go from-- because
it's kind of obvious right
now to see if you
have my emails,
and you know that I'm
traveling tomorrow to New York,
it's kind of simple to
do that on my calendar
and create an event.
How do you go from
robotic arms, trying
to understand how to get
things, to an actual product?
The question is, what is the
thought process behind it?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Yeah.
I'll give you the
short version of it.
And, obviously, there's
a longer version of it.
Wait for the medium post.
But I think the
short version of it
is, to echo one
thing JG said, you
want to pick problems
that are easy for machines
and hard for humans.
So AI plus machine
learning is not
going to turn a non-problem
into a real problem
that people need solving.
It's like, you can take
Christopher Nolan and Ben
Affleck, and you can still end
up with Batman Versus Superman.
So you want to make sure that
the problem you're solving
is a real one.
Many of our failures,
even internally
and external, like frenzy
around bots and AI,
is when you kid yourself that
the problem needs solving.
And the second one, the
second quick insight there,
is that you also want to
build an iterative model.
That is, you want to kind of
start small, and say, hey,
travel needs some assistance.
What are the top five things
that people need help with?
And see which of these
things can scale.
JEFF DEAN: I would
add one thing to that,
which is, often,
we're doing research
on a particular kind of problem.
And then, when we have
something we think is useful,
we'll share that internally,
as presentations or whatever,
and maybe highlight
a few places where
we think this kind of
technology could be used.
And that's sort of a good way
to inform the product designers
about what kinds of things
are now possible that
didn't used to be possible.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
Let's have another question
from the press section up there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
There's a lot of talk, lately,
about sort of a fear of AI.
Elon Musk likened it
to summoning the demon.
Whether that's overblown
or not, whether it's
perception versus
reality, there seems
to be a lot of mistrust
or fear of going
too far in this direction.
How much stock
you put into that?
And how do you win the
trust of the public, when
you show experiments
like the robot arm thing
on the keynote, which
was really cool, but sort
of simultaneously
creepy at the same time?
JOHN GIANNANDREA: So I
get this question a lot.
I think there's
this notion that's
been in the press for
the last couple of years
about so-called
super intelligence,
that somehow AI
will beget more AI,
and then it will be exponential.
I think researchers in the field
don't put much stock in that.
I don't think we think
it's a real concern yet.
In fact, I think
we're a long way away
from it being a concern.
There are some
researchers who actually
think about these
ethical problems,
and think about
AI safety, and we
think that's really important.
And we work on this
stuff with them,
and we support
that kind of work.
But I think it's a concern that
is decades and decades away.
It's also conflated
with the fact
that people look at things
like robots learning
to pick things up,
and that's somehow
inherently scary to people.
I think it's our job,
when we bring products
to market, to do it
in a thoughtful way
that people find
genuinely useful.
So a good example I would give
you is, in Google products,
when you're looking for a
place, like a coffee shop
or something, we'll
show you when it's busy.
And that's the product of
fairly advanced machine learning
that takes aggregate signals
in a privacy-preserving way
and says, yeah, this
coffee shop is really
busy on a Saturday morning.
That doesn't seem
scary to me, right?
anything like a bad thing
to bring into the world.
So I think there's a bit of a
disconnect between the somewhat
extended hype, and the
actual use of this technology
in everyday products.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So given Google's
source of revenue
and the high use of
ad blockers, is there
any possibility of
using machine learning
to maybe ensure that the
appropriate ads are served?
Or if there's multiple
versions of the same ad,
that the ad that
would apply most to me
would be served to me,
and to a different user,
a different version,
and things like that?
Is that on the roadmap?
JEFF DEAN: Yeah.
I think, in general,
there's a lot
of potential
applications of machine
learning to advertising.
Google has actually
been using machine
learning in our advertising
system for more than a decade.
And I think one of the
things about deciding
what ads to show
to users is, you
want them to be relevant
and useful to that user.
And it's better to
not show an ad at all,
if you don't have something
that seems plausibly relevant.
And that's always been Google's
advertising philosophy.
And other websites on the
web don't necessarily quite
have the same balance,
in that respect.
But I do think there's plenty
of opportunity to continue
to improve advertising
systems and make them better,
so that you see less ads, but
they're actually more useful.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
Next question from at the top.
JACK CLARK: Jack Clark
with Bloomberg News.
So how do you
differentiate to the user
between a sponsored advert, and
one that is provided by your AI
naturally?
How do I know that the burger
joint you're suggesting
is like a paid-for link,
or is it a genuine link?
JEFF DEAN: So in
our user interfaces,
we always clearly
delimit advertisements.
And in general, all
ads that we show
are selected algorithmically
by our systems.
They're not like, you
can just give us an ad,
and we will always
show it to someone.
We always decide what
is the likelihood
that this ad is going
to be useful to someone,
before we decide to show
that advertiser's ad.
JACK CLARK: Does this extend to
stuff like Google Home, where
it will say, this is
a sponsored restaurant
we're going to send you to.
JEFF DEAN: I don't
know that product.
JOHN GIANNANDREA:
I mean, we haven't
launched Google Home yet.
So a lot of these product
decisions are still to be made.
I think we do, as
a general rule,
clearly identify when
something is sponsored
versus when it's organic.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
Next question here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is a question
for Jeff Dean.
I'm very much intrigued by
the Google Brain project
that you're doing.
Very cool t-shirt.
The question is, what
is the road map of that,
and how does it relate to
the point of singularity?
JEFF DEAN: Aha.
So the road map of-- this is
sort of the project code name
for the team that I work on.
Basically, the
team was developed
to investigate the use
of advanced methods
in machine learning to solve
difficult problems in AI.
And we're continuing to
work on pushing the state
of the art in that area.
And I think that means working
in lots of different areas,
building the right kinds
of hardware with TPUs,
building the right systems
infrastructure with things
like TensorFlow.
Solving the right
research problems
that are not
connected to products,
and then figuring out ways
in which machine learning can
be used to advance
different kinds of fields,
as we solve different
problems along the road.
I'm not a big believer
in the singularity.
I think all exponentials
look like exponentials
at the beginning, but then
they run out of stuff.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
Thanks for the question.
Back to the pressbox.
STEVEN MAX PATTERSON: Hi.
Steven Max Patterson, IDG.
I was looking at Google
Home and Google Assistant,
and it looks like it's
really a platform.
And it's a composite
of other platforms,
like the Knowledge Graph, Google
Cloud Speech, Google machine
learning, the Awareness API.
Is this a feature that other
consumer device manufacturers
could include, and is that the
intent and direction of Google,
is to make this a platform?
JOHN GIANNANDREA:
It's definitely
the case that most of
our machine learning APIs
are migrating to the cloud
platform, which enables people
to use, for example, our speech
capabilities in other products.
I think the Google Assistant
is intended to be, actually,
a holistic product
delivered from Google.
That makes sense.
But it may make
sense to syndicate
that to other manufacturers
at some point.
We don't have any
plans to do that today.
But in general,
we're trying to be
as open as we can with
the component pieces
that you just
mentioned, and make
them available as Cloud
APIs, and in many cases,
as open source
solutions as well.
JEFF DEAN: Right.
I think one of the
things about that
is, making those
individual pieces available
enables everyone in the world
to take advantage of some
of the machine learning
research we've done,
and be able to do things
like label images,
or do speech
recognition really well.
And then they can
go off and build
really cool, amazing things
that aren't necessarily
the kinds of things
we're working on.
JOHN GIANNANDREA: Yeah, and many
companies are doing this today.
They're using our
translate APIs.
They're using our Cloud
Speech APIs today.
TOM SIMONITE: Right.
We have time for one last quick
question from this mic here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm [INAUDIBLE].
John, you said that you
would declare summer
if, in language
understanding, it
would be able to translate
from one paragraph in English
to another paragraph in English.
Don't you think that making
that possible requires
really complete understanding
of the world, and everything
that's going on, just to
catch the emotional level that
is in the paragraph, or even
the physical understanding
of the world around us?
JOHN GIANNANDREA: Yeah, I do.
I use that example because
it is really, really hard.
So I don't think we're going to
be done for many, many years.
I think there's a
lot of work to do.
We built the Google
Knowledge Graph, in part,
to answer that question,
so that we actually
had some semantic
understanding of at least
the things in the world, and
some of the relationships
between them.
But yeah, it's a
very hard problem.
And I used that
example because it's
pretty clear we won't
be done for a long time.
TOM SIMONITE: OK.
Sorry, there's no time
for other questions.
Thanks for the question.
A good forward-looking
note to end on.
We'll see how it works
out over the coming years.
Thank you for joining
me, all of you on stage,
and thanks for the questions
and coming for the session.
[MUSIC PLAYING]